[موسيقى] مفاوض
وسيط وسيط السلطة جميع
المصطلحات التي تم استخدامها لوصف
دور الرئيس التركي راجيف طيب أردوغان في حرب أوكرانيا خلال الـ
18 شهرًا الماضية
منذ البداية، وضع نفسه
كوسيط بين أوكرانيا
وروسيا ولكنه الدور الذي يأتي معه
بعض الفوائد الكبيرة للزعيم التركي
من ناحية، كانت تركيا واحدة من
أوائل الدول التي زودت أوكرانيا
بطائرات بدون طيار مقاتلة والتي سرعان ما أصبحت رمزًا
للمقاومة الأوكرانية،
وكان أردوغان صريحًا بشأن
اعتقاده بضرورة إعادة شبه جزيرة القرم التي احتلتها روسيا
إلى أوكرانيا
في وقت لاحق.  ومن ناحية أخرى، حافظ أردوغان على
علاقة وثيقة مع
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين، بل
وعزز العلاقات الاقتصادية مع روسيا
طوال فترة الصراع. وقد
ساعد أردوغان في التفاوض على العديد من
الصفقات الدبلوماسية الحاسمة. أول ما
توسطت فيه الأمم المتحدة في يوليو الماضي
هو مبادرة البحر الأسود الرمادية التي
سمحت بها.  التصدير الآمن للحبوب
من الموانئ الأوكرانية عبر البحر الأسود
وساعد في تخفيف أزمة الغذاء العالمية،
ثم ساعدت تركيا والمملكة العربية السعودية في سبتمبر الماضي في
التوسط في تبادل للأسرى
يشمل حوالي 300 أسرى، وهي أكبر عملية تبادل من هذا القبيل
منذ بداية الصراع
قبل حرب أردوغان.  كان منغمسًا في
حمامات السباحة في الداخل، لكن دوره في
الحرب الأوكرانية عزز صورته
محليًا قبل انتخابات مايو
التي فاز بها
بينما فرض الغرب عقوبات على
موسكو، ورفض أردوغان القيام بذلك بدلاً من
السماح للتجارة بين روسيا وتركيا
بالارتفاع و  بالطبع، تمتع أردوغان
بنفوذ جديد داخل حلف شمال الأطلسي لعدة
أشهر، وكان العقبة الرئيسية أمام
انضمام فنلندا والسويد إلى الحلف
بمجرد أن رفع معارضته
لطلب السويد الذي قالت الولايات المتحدة إنها ستمضي
قدمًا في نقل طائرات إف-16 التي
كانت طويلة الأمد.  بناءً على طلب دائم من أنقرة،
عزز أردوغان بلا شك
موقفه وموقف تركيا، ليس فقط
داخل المنطقة ولكن أيضًا على
المسرح العالمي، وطالما أن الحرب مستمرة،
يبدو أنها ستستمر.